ever since we heard that unmistakable
laughter at the end of the trailer for
Star Wars Episode nine the rise of
Skywalker
[Laughter]
we've been stunned that Emperor
Palpatine is returning for the
conclusion of the Skywalker saga more
than a few fans however are less stunned
than peeved they want to know why on
earth director JJ Abrams and co-writer
Chris Terrio would bring back a big bad
who has supposedly been dead for more
than 30 years could they simply not
think of any other way to raise the
stakes of the sequel story what kind of
narrative gymnastics will rise of
Skywalker have to engage in to make this
plot development make sense how exactly
can this even happen Palpatine is a
central figure in both the original and
prequel trilogy he starts as a Sith Lord
in disguise serving as a senator in the
Galactic Republic where he engineers the
rise of the Empire he successfully turns
Anakin Skywalker to the dark side of the
force and nearly achieves complete
dominance over the galaxy it's
ultimately his rage at his inability to
turn anakin son Luke to the dark side
that's his undoing at the conclusion of
Star Wars Episode six Return of the Jedi
Palpatine attempts to manipulate Luke
into killing his father Anakin aka Darth
Vader but the plan fails when Luke
refuses to fight Palpatine attempts to
simply kill the young Jedi assaulting
him with Force Lightning as Vader
watches but Vader turns away from the
dark side and toward Redemption
he seizes the Emperor and tosses him
down a seemingly bottomless shaft
mortally wounding himself in the process
he seemingly kills Palpatine and brings
balance to the force the sequel trilogy
picks up 30 years after these events as
the remnants of the Empire are reforming
into the nefarious first order under the
guidance of the Supreme Leader Snoke and
his protege kylo Ren Ren is Ben
Skywalker's son of han Solo and general
Leia and a former apprentice of Luke's
Star Wars Episode 7 the force awakens
clearly seems to set up Snoke as the big
bad of the sequel trilogy but midway
through Star Wars Episode eight the last
Jedi kylo Ren kills Snoke leaving the
trilogy without a top bad guy it's time
to little things done snoke's death was
puzzling for many fans and was a major
factor in the backlash that the last
Jedi endured from some Star Wars fans
the tea's a Palpatine's returned to the
franchise stoked the ire of these fans
even further as the move is easy to
interpret as an attempt by Abrams and
company to cash in on nostalgia for the
original series after all Palpatine has
not been featured in the sequel series
up to this point and resurrecting him
could be seen as lazy writing his return
raises so many questions does it lessen
Darth Vader's heroic sacrifice are we
supposed to now buy that Palpatine has
been pulling strings for all of the
intervening years between the original
and sequel trilogies and nobody is
caught on did he actually die and return
somehow or did he actually survive
getting the heave-ho down a bottomless
shaft the degree to which one is willing
to go along with this plot wrinkle is
going to depend largely on trust in
Abrams in a recent interview with Empire
magazine the director made it known that
he's aware that some fans are confused
and he attempted to reassure those fans
that he knows what he's doing he said
some people feel like we shouldn't
revisit the idea of Palpatine and I
completely understand that but if you're
looking at these nine films as one story
I don't know many books where the last
few chapters have nothing to do with
those that have come before if you look
at the first eight films all the setups
of what we're doing in rise of Skywalker
are there in plain view one thing we
know is that Palpatine's appearance will
be no mere cameo he's going to be
instrumental to the events of episode 9
and if a recent leak detailing his
involvement in the narrative turns out
to be accurate his return can actually
end up making a great deal more sense
than it might initially seem to we'll
find out the reasoning behind
Palpatine's return and surely find out
how fans feel about it when star wars
episode 9 the rise of Skywalker hits the
big screen December 20th check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]